[Music]
how are y'all doing
it's after lunch well we got a fantastic
panel coming up shortly to wake you all
up and you guys heard today's keynote
yesterday s keynotes
a lot of good stuff about AI and ml and
we are going to show you how a and ml it
can be applied across the value chain
and this is the theme bridge from
marketing to supply chain I am solid on
one car I am the CEO of Pluto seven more
importantly I also lead a I and ml
professional services team and I have
the good fortune of having some of my
customers sitting along with me will
join me shortly on this panel so without
further ado being in the business for
such a long time
and I've worked as both an employee of a
large corporation and a management
consultant and now I'm working as
helping companies come up and do DRI
breakthrough innovation using the latest
technologies the key thing that has
stood out for me is that typically lot
of enterprises end up in having focus on
the front what I call as the front end
of the enterprise value chain i defined
that more as marketing the front end of
the whole business the customer facing
side of a business in the value chain
marketing sales and then you have the
operations and the supply chain which
for our reference I will define as the
back end typically there's been a lot of
focus on how do you make the
profitability of the enterprise or the
customer experience that an enterprise
can provide its customers seamless and
we've seen time and time again that this
has pretty much been a challenge even
though there have been advances in
technology just to illustrate that I
just I thought this was a very apt quote
from Mark Anderson pretty much he
captured this very well saying that well
there were a lot of technical
breakthrough technology possibilities
really the business there was a
challenge in how business could achieve
the results in despite those
technological innovations and that it
was not only the fact that it was the
business who was willing to drive but
there were technology challenges that
still stopped the business from
attaining those goals so that falls very
perfectly with my opening statement
which is essentially the key to all this
driving the business benefit starts by
making sure that you are able to take
the process the process dia is basically
people process and technology and have
it work seamlessly from the front to the
back it starts with the customer and
ends with the customer but for you guys
as enterprises there's always the front
end or the demand generation the
marketing side of the processes and then
you have your fulfillment processes
which are mostly operational that deals
with supply chain so the key thing is AR
and ml proposes some possibilities to
have a responsive back-end that can go
hand-in-hand with the front end and
today's teams as you will see in the
breakout I mean in the panel discussion
is to give you some ideas on how we can
see that happening or in fact what are
the challenges that still exist that
need to be overcome
in order to make it even better and how
does AI and ML fall into the strategic
aspect as well as the tactical aspect of
enabling this so lot of companies have
already started using AI on the
marketing side on the to some extent
even on the customer relationship
management and sales ai has been seen to
have given very good results in this
area the key is whether we can follow
that up
and leverage AI and m/l also on the
operations and supply chain and that
piece is still evolving
so just to encapsulate this pretty much
some of the key things here are you can
come up with a very good efficient and
targeted marketing leading to
competitive advantage that can be
achieved through AI and ml it has been
achieved through traditional analytics
to some extent and you will see my
panelists talk about it and then the key
here is on the operation side is doing
exception based demand planning time and
time again when I provided solutions to
large customers and even small customers
even though they have been good
solutions and some of you are aware of
that them like sa P Oracle value chain
planning sa P's advanced supply chain
planning every time we implemented the
customer I still come back and ask why
can't I do exception based planning
meaning I need to only know where the
demand where do I have to pay attention
to my demand and where do I have to pay
attention to my supply so these are
typical outcomes that where people have
started using nml we have seen and again
will go as the panel is talked about it
hopefully this comes out it really helps
for example in coming up with the 360
view of the customer and that leads to
increasing for example your marketing
campaign efficiencies and helps drive
revenue on the front end on the back end
it really helps if you do this right by
coming up with the goods customer
experience especially in retail where
retail has to be very responsive
especially with omni-channel etc and you
it allows you to do this while
maintaining productivity and
profitability and to really come to this
piece where you can have the true
benefits you have to see some sort of
implementation across the enterprise
that's the goal so
how can ml drive your transformation of
your business these are the three key
elements in that whole value chain and
then there's the marketing ml there's a
demand ml and there's a supply Mel I'm
just simplifying this you heard
yesterday and today a lot of AI and ml
making things simpler so to keep it
simple and easy those are the branding
that we have come up with and we'll
expand into this in the panel so without
further ado I would like to invite my
panelists up here to join me and we have
a great set of panelists today they are
our customers and we will talk with them
on each of their experiences that deal
with the front end and the back end of
the process what are their thoughts what
are their what do they see as strategic
elements the tactical elements and their
experiences in trying to leverage AI and
ml in accomplishing what I just said
[Applause]
so before we start the panel discussion
I would like each one of you to
introduce yourself my name is Vikram I
work as a senior manager for a REM L
group in Cisco I'm su docker I run the
enterprise applications at synaptics
just brief overview of the company we
make electing that you interact with an
electronic device Solutions behind those
interactions like we touch orbit we
fingerprint solution or you might be
ordering pizza or something on your Alex
our device so we make solutions for wise
finger print and touch so it would be
easy for you to get that context when I
speak about how we have utilized ml hi
I'm Adam spun burg I lead the global
tech exploration part in supply for a be
in Bev
so that's anheuser-busch for those of
you don't know so beer production on a
global level across all the continents
hi I'm Deepak my ultra chief adventurer
at California design then we make
something very simple Google wants you
to be on cloud we want you to sleep on
cloud we make bedding products and from
a typical design manufacturing
white-label goods for retailers in North
America a couple of his years back we
turn to the b2c side and now I like a
retailer so we'll talk more thank you so
I don't know how many of you attended
adam's presentation yesterday he went
into more detail on some of the things
around what they have done preventive
maintenance you mention some of it again
here today but that was an excellent
presentation you can go back and review
it as you know those are still available
to be
later on Thank You Adam so let's start
vikram with you and you may want to keep
the mic closer sure so we talked about
AI and ml and I presented the front end
and the back end of the processes and
then we talked about lost opportunity
right and there's Marc Anderson's quote
which sort of talks a little bit about
the same thing what's your perspective
at a very high level I agree with this
code but at the same time technology the
enabler of the vision that we have to
put in in the front if we don't have the
vision then technology is not going to
help us in the long run there are a lot
of examples like Google Amazon all these
companies where technology was not there
when they started it so if the vision
was not there and if the willingness of
taking that vision to reality was not
there technology would not help us now
there are a lot of use cases also where
technology came in and as a human being
when we learned somebody else doing
something we try to we try to see how we
can take benefit of the same concept and
evolve to the next level so there are a
lot of examples in that as well so so it
is a philosophical debate but it depends
on how you want to take it I think ideas
and the willingness to take those ideas
to execution and more important than
technology agree so the problem of the
demand-supply matching and
time-to-market were always there so we
had to look into solutions that could
help us to bridge the gap as to optimize
our inventory so recently for the last
couple of years we have realized that
there is ml and there are technological
improvements wherein we could leverage
those and that technology to bridge
those gaps so now we think we are at
that point where and we could leverage
ml significantly to to achieve our goals
any comments sure I think you know one
thing interesting about that quote it
focuses on the 90s as if where we stand
today we
solved all the problems that prevented
those businesses from succeeding then
but I think you know this is a universal
construct that will probably continue to
happen and people with great vision
today may have ideas that aren't
possible now but might be more more
available in 10 to 15 years so I'd go so
far as to say that I agree with this
quote and actually think it's kind of
prophetic in some ways about how
technology works but as we advanced
maybe with such exponential growth that
gap will diminish and we'll be closer
and closer between vision and technology
I think what Adams head is so perfect
which is you know exponential growth and
bridging the gap I don't think any of
any one of us in the room can imagine a
world where only large companies with
deep pockets are going to rule so the
machines are here whether they going to
take over the world or not that's a
philosophy cultivate we can have but you
know as a as a business that that is not
big let's let's pick up a fight with
Amazon for now which happens to be our
number one channel but also happens to
be our competition the question is what
do we do that we are in the race
we are not behind it we can hopefully
then compete and how would we scale how
would we optimize how would we reduce
wastages so all those questions for any
business around
it's very fairly simple I mean it's it's
not going to be easy but if you're not
in the race you will be out of it so
with that in mind things are only going
to get very interesting so following
that your comments earlier how do you
what is it about that perspective that
you would like to relate in the work
that for example you are doing in your
area or even from your thought processes
as it relates to like marketing and
sales and
absolutely there are a lot of scenarios
that we are currently working on for
example when we started this journey two
years ago it was always about customer
success mission how once you achieve
once you bought something how do we
drive the value of that product as soon
as possible to the customer and the key
concept over there was how can we
understand what you are looking for from
our software and where are the issues
what are the challenges that you are
facing and how do we provide that
information using the resister channels
or within the product as well now we
sell you guys all know Cisco's has so
many product and so many software's it's
just not possible
humanly to do all of that so we had to
we had to apply them we had to use the
machine to start with we had to go with
business rules but later on we went into
AI and all those things there is from a
technology point of view I still feel
that there is a lot of scope in
technology improvement for example when
we look at a ai ai today is very
specialized ai it can do certain things
but when you look at generic AI is still
not there yet and I don't think the
technology is even there - but we cannot
just think about technology as a
roadblock but think about what can we do
what exists today and what is it that we
want to drive so when we started this
journey it was more about can we know
our customers better like customer
segmentation customer journey how did
they use the product what are the
features that they use what they want to
achieve what should we tell them to use
them more and through all digital
channels how we can communicate that
information back to the customer and
then see what works what doesn't work so
this thing's took a lot of effort but
this is where we are heading towards and
we are working tirelessly to to meet
these goals very good you mentioned a
very good thing or you mentioned journey
so sue doctor if I may ask you he gave
the perspective from the digital
marketing what's your perspective on
this a IML journey as it relates to like
supply planning
my operations so the space where
synaptics is and it's in a high-tech
world fast-moving products and cell
phones and tablets and laptops and at
the market that we are on or the the
alex is in the world so the our time to
market and we have to make sure that our
inventory is optimized right at the same
time you don't want to leave any money
on the table so our use case was hey if
you have to optimize the inventory then
how do we go about then we have Wow
absolutely we wanted to focus on the
demand so though our goal was inventory
optimization so we thought why not start
looking into demand there's a lot of
fluctuation there's a lot of inputs
coming from different parts of the world
and things are changing as you can see I
think the cell phone that the life of a
cell phone is pretty and small when
compared to some of the other products
so we had to look into areas where we
could look into demand right how would
we try to look into demand predictive
analytics kind of things so that's when
we we thought that why not start looking
into ml and so our journey has been B
thought and let's start looking at if we
can have ml predict our forecast for the
stable mature product so obviously the
goal was to do the inventory
optimization so it's been a great
journey we did get to a point where in
for certain mature products we we do
have getting some confidence that maybe
we can't start leveraging ml to start
predicting our forecast as you mentioned
before so we can focus on the exceptions
so standard products everything that's
matured maybe ml will drive the demand
and the rest of it be managed by
exception so it's been a great journey
so far taking from that and I'm a Adam
if I may ask you to add to what sue
doctor just said but you would you did a
phenomenal
your company did a phenomenal
work in applying AI and ml working with
us to really come up I mean do a change
that was sounds simple right which you
presented in great detail yesterday what
are your thoughts that you would like to
share with this audience in allowing the
AI and ml journey through a for
innovation and breakthrough business
benefits taking that as an example so
that they can understand like for
somebody who wants to embark on that
journey what are the things that one
should pay attention to sure and I think
you know a B and bedstand
stands out a little bit from the other
companies on this panel because the work
that we're doing is not so much software
based you know we're a manufacturing
company more or less we're creating beer
and so you probably wonder where - where
does machine learning and artificial
intelligence play in there well actually
in very many places and I think we're
just scratching the surface so to go
into the specific example where Pluto 7
is working with us is we found that we
could predict a much more accurate
filtration process by using an
artificial intelligence it's pretty
remarkable how you can study certain
variables by going through the data and
having enough data to do that and be
able to predict with much keener
accuracy when you should replace a
filter in that fermentation process so
it's pretty extraordinary thing and you
know there's so much that goes into
making beer for example that you know
this is just one example that we're
starting with to see how this how
effective AI can be and you know we're
very optimistic about those results so I
think you know spawning off on that any
part of maintenance could be predictive
maintenance it could be something in our
packaging lines it could be something
with maybe more along what you were
suggesting predicting inventory or
customer demand there's really the sky's
the limit on this and I think you know
for all of you out there they're
involved in companies are considering
this this really does seem
the most cutting-edge way to make that
next a huge bump in advancement toward
the future thank you and debug if I may
ask you you are a fast growing retailer
if a lot of business growth and scaling
is something that is always at the top
of your mind so with that in mind and
related to what a demands so that I just
discussed what's your perspective for us
at California designed in our focus has
also been trying to tie the two ends
which is demand forecasting and supply
chain the whole question of optimization
of supply chain being like a start-up
again
with limited resources and you know
growth that's surprising and clearing
anything that we had ever forecasted it
became very important for us to ensure
that the decisions are near real-time
and again you know managing by exception
now I mean imagine I mean how many of
you really think that a bed sheet you
know that's what one of the key products
we make needs a retail shelf space on
the seventh floor at Macy's I mean
really do we really need a huge floor of
selling bed sheets how many of you would
go there and be able to actually open
one of those bags and feel it probably
not so we see products like ours which
are fairly commoditized completely being
online and therefore the growth is
phenomenal and we are competing with our
channels whether it's Walmart comma or
amazon.com so it becomes very important
for us to be very nimble be fast and in
the journey towards you know from from
from basically ensuring our all our data
is in one place everything is flowing
into one place having a very distributed
supply chain running from here to
factories in India and China we have
been taking on this journey and saying
you know very good results of course
those results are are still very basic
whether it's inventory reduction or its
you know
speed in making decisions for changing
what is in production line but how we
are looking at ML and then AI is that as
we scale up and we you know we face this
hyper competition we would be ready for
whether its demand forecasting supply
chain planning price optimization and
what-have-you thank you
so Vikram coming back to you and
marketing right on a similar theme
now that you've considered you've looked
at I think you always drove the envelope
when it came to technology because you
have to do that in digital marketing
what are the consideration especially
around going on about your AI and m/l
journey that you want to point out right
that would be of interest to this
audience so one of the things that I
would say we have been using a lot of
prediction based modeling earlier we
used to call it as forecasting for like
late nineties in Cisco from a supply
chain point of view but this motion of
using the data science not from
forecasting perform prediction point of
view is pretty new and from strategical
angle there are multiple things which
comes top of the mind there is a big
hype around AI nml a lot of companies
today are investing because they feel is
a magic and it's one silver bullet which
will solve all of their problems but I
would just caution it is not a magic
it's not a it's not one silver bullet
which will solve your problem it it's a
big step forward and it requires a lot
of things thought process change in the
company itself your business objective
should be very very clear a second thing
is the way you use it from a technology
and from data point of view data science
and AI can only work on the data itself
if you don't have the data in a way that
could be useful machine it doesn't mean
that you need to have Amazon or Google
like exabytes or petabytes kind of data
but you should have enough diversify
that you could use it from machine or
algorithm and the third thing is as I
said it's not a silver bullet it
requires a lot of work sharing the data
in and there should be a willingness to
take that insights from the ml and put
them into the process sometimes we get a
lot of insights but when we're trying to
drive the experience with the customers
like cisco.com for example when we want
to say this customer wants to only learn
about this tell them that message it
goes into that Channel oh we know more
how can should this be the message or no
we this page cannot be customized for an
example so sometimes it's in the front
end kind of work it becomes a little
difficult when you have the insight you
know what customer wants but when you
want to show that message to customer
your tools platform doesn't support so
there are a lot of constraints I will
just caution that first from a
statistical point of view that AI is not
not which can be implemented tomorrow it
takes it takes some it takes time
especially in a big company like Cisco
the second thing from tactical point of
view is normal activities like what is
it till the time if your business
objectives are clear till the time you
get there what is how can you keep on
adding the value in the process because
everybody thinks about AI they always
think about either optimization whether
it's a cost or process or you say how
can I get the innovation or competitive
advantage and how can I use it to extend
my business to the next level but all of
these things when you go to the tactical
level these things will take time and
technically you cannot wait for a couple
of years to produce the results so you
have to understand what those business
challenges are where the things could
immediate here at the value so for
example we were lucky enough that we
were part of the sales organization and
there are a lot of companies which has
done a lot of things for the sales
already so we had to take those
learnings and see adjust to our own
culture so for example customer churn
model customer risk analysis life cycle
advantage product recommendation all
those things but what is the right
contact on this company what is the
timing that you should call that guy
what
that prescriptive insight when you talk
to that customer all of these things
came came in handy
to drive that immediate value that we
had to show step by step before we get
to that bigger goal
the second thing from a customer success
point of view was all about how do we
provide the right relevant message to
the customer and change that experience
so so tactically it's more around how
can you keep on adding the value but
only when you're strategical objectives
are very clear very good points there I
heard data folk keeping focus on data
which we heard even during some of the
keynotes I heard Shawn mentioned that
yesterday in and then also people always
when you talk about a and M L it's all
about data and then understanding where
you want to go so sue doctor similarly
any insights you want to talk about in
the first MLA I like a proof of concept
that you did that we would like to point
out I think it has to be tightly
integrated with business planning so we
just it's not just about having data and
trying to come up with a magic formula
that it's going to predict especially
for our use case it was demand plan come
up with an accurate demand plan so you
have to be tightly integrated with
business planning as to what are the
elements that go into a business plan
one has to work with the given amount of
data that is available to put those
things along with the the algorithms
that the ml can come up with so it's not
just throwing in data and then it's
going to spit out an end result and
that's going to be an accurate forecast
that's not happening so we the the
business plan anything that's subjective
objective or anything that you're
getting from the field data when one is
creating that demand plan and the
business plan any element that goes into
their thought process we have to make
sure that the the ml can we could try to
incorporate as much as you can only then
maybe it starts understanding that
there's not one thing that you look into
and your entry
and so if you are the person that's
responsible for next year maybe yeah
whatever how many folks are going to
attend this conference so it's not it
could not be one factor or two for you
to accurately predict that similarly we
had to get into that it has to be very
tightly integrated with the overall
business plan and it mean like he said
it's not something that comes out
automatically so you have to then look
into what what products can you really
apply that and that's going to be more
helpful so we're still in a very early
stage but we do see some positive
results of course some places there are
disappointments so we just have to
continue to tweak it and fine-tune it
and get to a point so it's it's
extremely important to put those all the
elements that are there in a business
plan into it so it's been a great
journey as to some we had some successes
and some obviously you still have to
learn from deeper right it's not magic
it requires work so Tucker mentioned
that hey there has to be focus and plan
behind in your example one of the things
that I heard and I want to relate it to
your experience right that was presented
in the keynote today by Rajan says it's
all about simple AI and I think in your
case what we achieved or if what you
achieved was something that at the end
became very simple right so any thoughts
around that well you know one thing I
think is interesting about what we're
all trying to do here and you know I'll
use our case with a B and F as an
example is we're talking so much about
machine learning but what are we really
trying to relate to that's humans so
it's it's kind of an irony in a way that
we're using a machine to better
understand ourselves so you know and
then until we enter a world where maybe
robots are running everything and then
they'll be marketing to themselves who
knows but for now it's all about that
human aspect and that actually doesn't
just go for consumers that's also with
the
the organization itself and that's you
know a battle that you know I've had to
fight and I don't say that as a negative
thing I think it's about educating and
getting more and more people aligned
especially a big company like ours ABN
Bev has 250,000 employees or somesuch
so this you're not going to have 250,000
people on board with AI from day one and
certainly not key stakeholders who
aren't familiar with the technologies
yet and haven't had a chance to really
understand the value that it can bring
so I think you know you say simple AI
but what I would kind of taking a play
on those words I think a real key for us
if we want to lead this AI revolution is
to find a way to simplify the message
how can we show this value to everybody
top up and down that they can see what
we can achieve and that it's not a
threat if anything it's an enhancement
thank you
deepak any comments I think as far as ml
nei is concerned you know it's it's more
like a journey right so as you said it's
not a magic bullet and the biggest
advantage that that we feel at
California designed in trying to ensure
that we set the vision that this is what
is going to drive competitive advantage
when product differentiation may not be
a differentiating factor this kind of
drives us as a company to set everything
in place so it's not that we have to set
up some new system that's only going to
do ml base demand forecasting right so
whether it is basic analytics to
advanced analytics or you know what have
you it's it's like a journey right so
but once you have a vision that this is
where you need to be and many of those
visions are still visionary visions this
does bring in a lot of efficiencies it
kind of becomes a rallying point between
the key stakeholders you there's the you
know there's an added advantage where
you'll have to relook at all your
processes and what have you
because as Adam said you know not
everyone
on board right away so you know you kind
of internally debate figure out what you
do you know kind of break old moles make
new ones so we see a IML not just in
what we expect it to produce after few
years but also as a driving force
towards being you know on your feet and
you know just pushing hard and you know
being being in the front
so between Vikram you and sadaqa you
sort of represent the high tech industry
right I would like to hear Vikram first
to you and then so that were following
him your thoughts on
now that you have embarked on this AI
and ml and started using it at least
getting to understand how to use it in
your respective spaces I would like I
think you articulated in some places
that okay it's a journey what you see
right in the high tech space where do
you see AI lab being leveraged more and
where do you want to give this audience
okay here you might be tempted to go
into AI but you may want to go with a
little bit of caution right because I
think one of the things that what I'm
trying to understand is in your
experience that I'm sure that what the
audience would like to understand is as
you are going through this journeys
there are learnings like okay because AI
everybody wants to get into the ml
bandwagon but not every use case may be
meant for AI and ml so any perspective
taking that into consideration so when
we talk about a high your ml there are
always risk and benefits to that as well
when we talk about any model or any
recommendation there is always a
percentage of accuracy and and one of
the things that I was talking earlier
was when we look at the ml today these
are specialized models specialized model
learning from the data about previous
behavior with this set of behaviors this
was outcomes at car driven and that
drives your prediction about what shall
you do tomorrow because there's the same
pattern which will repeat the same thing
as zooming that so when we took put the
models in we get one thing is
we cannot just blindly trust the model
there has to be some way off of
understanding what those models or
outputs are talking about put the human
intelligence around it and then say does
the sense does this cases even make
sense or not so when we were working on
a project customer segmentation which we
are still working on to evolve it to a
next level we realized that we were able
to divide our customer in around for
that one particular product the customer
set into like 16 different segments but
when we looked at with the business
owners trying to understand what does it
really represent and how shall we drive
the experience of each of these segments
or each of this set of customers half of
them did not even make sense to them
because it was more around you know what
this seems pretty much similar to that
their their messaging will be little
different so why don't we merge it
together this sense that this one does
not even make sense because these things
is like if everyone is using perfectly
then what we will do with them so when
we look at the machine and these kind of
risk we cannot blindly trust the machine
yet it's a specialized AI which does the
specialized things even better than
human in certain aspect aspect but human
supervision in putting that to the
motion is still very much required that
intuition of looking let's say this
patterns meant customer will order but
those patterns does not mean much in
today's environment how can we how can
we understand from it how can we apply
our human knowledge and how can we keep
it always tuned in into the realistic
business scenario becomes the most
important work in AI it's not just
getting the data getting meaningful data
driving the insight and putting the
insight to work but it's all about
taking that model making an intelligent
decision around it and then putting it
to work which which makes it a recursive
cycle so so human interaction is is very
important in my opinion to take this AI
to the market maybe when the technology
was in in certain time and when we have
general-purpose AI and then it's a
different story but but for now
it's a specialized AI and MLS have
specialized model based on the data it
should not be taken on the face value
there are certain use cases like vision
detection and all those things where a
is already improved beyond human
capability but when we talk about
business sense of what makes sense and
what does not I think putting it blind
you blind trust in that and and taking
the action on that without supervision
can produce more data can be can produce
more risk than advantage as well in
certain scenarios okay thank you
anything the summary what you said is a
any AI solution requires technology and
domain and business expertise and the
second thing is there are models that
can be leveraged as is winning like what
they call as the pre-built models right
vision API you talked about but there
are certain situations and some of the
most of the business situations where
you have to have a custom model thank we
we took it a little bit of a simplistic
approach wherein obviously like a
dimension first thing was ml is going to
predict my demand no way so you can ml
really predict what kind of dinner are
you gonna have no way so obviously there
was that that kind of thinking within
the company then we took much more
simplistic approach as to okay in all
the different product lines or different
customers or segments let's pick
something that's where you think there
could be a little bit of more
predictability within the human thinking
so within your own thinking there could
be certain things that you are more more
consistent in your thinking and there
could be some where you are you are
trying to gather additional data to
digest and come up with a solution so or
an answer so we then we had to dig
through those questions as to okay what
are the areas where you could be more
consistent the customer could be more
consistent a market could be more
consistent so we can drive our inventory
optimization by understanding how the
demand is being generated so we picked
up more of those mature products or
markets or
and then so obviously the acceptance has
to come into picture that hey what the
machine is predicting is pretty much
close to what can I rely on it so you
have to take the use case wherein one
starts getting confidence and so
obviously you want to pick up the the
products and the markets and there are a
little bit more consistent obviously the
value is in the unpredictability where
it can predict but you can't start with
that so we took a simplistic approach
let's take baby steps so we are at that
stage for we came up with the first use
case now we'll take it to the next level
can I really apply to the NPI new
product introduction oh we don't know we
will I think that's that's to be seen
thank you I think the summary there is
crawl walk and then run I think from a
beam birth perspective you presented a
very great region in your discussion
yesterday I think as a representative of
the manufacturing industry because I
look at a be in bath I mean as one of
the large largest breweries and you can
say it's representing the manufacturing
industry what would your takeaway be
from that perspective around usage of
ein ml sure and I I do have to say you
keep saying we did this great
presentation but honestly give yourself
some credit
you know Pluto seven is the company that
really did the machine learning in AI we
just accepted it and put it into our
system so all credit to you guys but you
know I'd say this you have to find use
cases that make sense and I think this
is you know very in line with with what
was being said before is that the fact
is AI is not going to be the right
solution for a lot of things I think
there will be more and more use cases as
technology advances and you know
foundational layers of technology so say
in our breweries the more advanced our
data collection is for example the more
opportunities will emerge where we can
do things with that data but it's it's
essential that you really do have the
right situations and I think that's
where someone could run after this a
little irresponsible
and guess gets so excited about the AI
machine-learning idea that say oh we can
do ml everywhere and that's that's
really not true I mean if you were gonna
go swimming in a children's pool you
wouldn't say let's go buy scuba gear you
know to do that you know there's certain
things you have to find the right
setting and I think that's a combination
of in our case working together with
experts who really do know the right
situation in the case of Pluto 7 with us
you know we actually held a hackathon
where we explored a number of areas
where we thought a I could be valuable
and we look to them to come up with a
model that worked and from those
different options it became apparent
that we had found something here so I
think you know to pursue something in
this space for all of you I would just
make sure that it's a prudent decision
definitely I'm not trying to stop
anybody's excitement be as passionate as
possible but you know save yourself the
trouble of overdoing it for the wrong
situations Thank You Adam and then
before we open it up to the audience
debug final thoughts from you as a
representative of the retail industry
and high growth as far as representing
retail that mr. Bezos would be better
off but you know I'm thinking like ml AI
is like a little baby right so you know
you start putting in data you still have
to you know kind of feed and change the
diapers and that's where we are right
now we are hoping that in a few years
this baby is gonna grow up and she's
gonna run and she's going to do pole
vault which I never did and you know
she's gonna win Olympic medals which I
couldn't even dream of so this is this
is pretty much how we are looking at ml
nai right so it's with us we have to
pick you know with this we are driven to
ensure that we think future we set up
systems dataflow you know rethink
processes and then like for example
the planning in a box that we did with
the Pluto seven you know if you were
able to see some good results as far as
demand forecasts and supply chain
optimizing is concerned so we press a
button you know we see what's going on
we quickly change what's in the supply
chain I mean it's still basic there's a
speed now so 500 1000 2000 SKUs that we
have to manage we are able to do it
quick and really fast now when will this
baby grow up and just take all charge
well we'll see when thank you I think
with that I'd like to open this up to
the audience we have about five minutes
left
it's more for you I guess we didn't use
any package I think I will leave it I
live it to the park yes people the
question is is there any packaged
application out there that can help
jumpstart their business well
it'll sound like a sponsored ad but you
know we used planning in a box that
Pluto 7 has which uses of course Google
Cloud and ml nai things within the
Google ecosystem that did help us a lot
as far as our inventory controls are
concerned so with you know much very
fast demand very decent demand
forecasting and a quick connection to
supply chain we were able to you know
see very visible inventory reductions so
right I think more with the fast movers
because again you got you know we as a
company are slow movers are really slow
so you know one of the disadvantages as
we were talking earlier you need to have
data to run some of these morals and see
real results so our slow movers are
really slow mover so you know we didn't
expect actually some of the results to
be benefitting the slow moving SKUs and
what have you so we kept our safety
stock levels in that case and worried
more about you know what was really
selling and where we had growth any
other question
okay if not I think that's pretty much
it feel free to drop by our booth at
Pluto 7:00 I have to put it up there we
can show you more demos on what's
possible with the A&M
[Music]